[Applaudissements]
à séoul en corée du sud la cuisine de
rue et m ces pauvres ainsi qu'aux beaux
essais
après l'école moi mes amis on va faire
un gogo c'est parce que c'est pas cher
ou les enfants mais c'est vraiment beau
[Musique]
jean gros est d'origine coréenne il est
gérant chez changchun d'un quartier
chinois à montréal cette chaîne de
restauration rapide prépare le pogo
coréen très populaire en asie et un peu
partout dans le monde
appelait
koungou avec un cas pour corinne ou kogo
avec un psy pour covéa il n'en demeure
pas moins un propos
le coco c'est un petit peu différence
parce que la croûte sébaste et ricoh la
ferme était beaucoup plus d'heures alors
il donnait une valeur et textes vraiment
spécial alors on choisit un kogo
original ou un moitié-moitié c'est à
dire saucisse et fromage soit mozzarella
ou cheddar et pourquoi pas à l'encré de
seiche ensuite on choisit l'enrobage
nature la date nous ramène et on réduit
sur la rue saint denis à montréal pitino
yens d'origine vietnamienne a eu lui
aussi l'appel du congo il a ouvert la
petite dînette au look dana américains
mais en version cuisine de rue razia tic
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui existe au dynamo
s'est même aujourd'hui ces saucisses de
boeuf au centre la saucisse est beaucoup
plus parfumé pour faire la pâte à
l'extérieur ce mélange de farine avec la
base de riz enseignants dans le mélange
de blé
emballé avec le ramène coquin avec les
patates et à une patte normal
de nouveaux
[Musique]
bugs
les coréens sont tellement friands de ce
pot go que beaucoup de recettes maison
envahissent le web moi je serais tenté
d'essayer avec un moitié moitié oui
celui là c'est un motivateur et la
primauté social autrement dit comment
exactement la première fois c'est un peu
difficile mais la technique c'est comme
ça faut ajouter rôle est
coupée et peut couvrir tous les motards
ont
roulé
nous ait fait part fin du premier coup
et là tu roules ici oui c'est ça
[Musique]
la date en quelques minutes
je choisis tu laisses aussi si vous
savez le maillot qui s'est massée près
du réac et switches et ketchup le pic a
review d'armes ou tas de miel vous allez
poudres c'est le canal le anigo reliques
sur les correcteurs moi c'est le
classique aurait un sens car ils ont
mangé la catch up avec les sucres
simples beaucoup de sucre que les sauces
c'est juste comme ça pour beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
vraiment intéressant c'est vraiment
craquant la part de huit blessés légers
aussi
[Musique]
la voilà voilà mais si le coup
juste pour moi ça va partager celles
associées spicam mon poulet au poulet
ont toujours été comme ça
très bon ce qui est amusant avec ce mais
là c'est que le pain de différentes
façons à robbie de faire un point sur
les différentes sources que je cac 40 ou
50 possibilités
[Rires]
et comme si ce n'était pas suffisant il
ya même des corps goût sucré on a réussi
un chocobo c'est une désert j'ai acheté
les canettes
le lighting chômeurs
parce que c'était pas à s'excuser de
genre ou sacrifiés
le kobo est là qui peuvent c'est
vraiment la tradition des corps et si
vous écoutez à la kpop
c'est comme orange ces accords et oui le
pauvre c'est la même chose manger un cow
boy c'est le sentiment comme marchal et
la rue de soto qui vous c'est la mémoire
c'est la jeunesse c'est abstrait
alors que cela